let me show you this tweet right here we
have this tweet from Andrew Kaczynski
you know me I love him he says every
single County moved further right in New
York this year if it comes down to just
a few seats New York Democrats and
backlash to democratic policies rule in
New York will have cost them the house
so hokel wins
zeldin loses but what how many votes did
he lose by so he lost by about 350 and I
told you right before we started that
over the last I think it's three years
in New York they've lost over 550 000
people so if you just look at that math
alone zeldin had people not moved but
you know you have to put in a zillion
factors because Kobe made everybody
crazy and everything else but it's like
zeldin could have won the fact that he
even got up this close and they flipped
some of these seats is incredible like
that guy is the All-Star DeSantis
obviously is the the starter All-Star
from this thing but but zeldin is a
close second every single District in
New York shifted left I mean just one
more time every single County look at
that
sorry sorry sorry shifted right shifted
to from the left to the right it's all
one thing when you look at it from space
far enough left and you end up on the
right but you but you mentioned 550 000
people I remember covering that story uh
hundreds of thousands from Manhattan
from Manhattan left and who would be
more likely to leave people who want
freedom where did they go across the
United States they went to Florida First
Texas second and what do we see both of
them became more red they they and
Georgia as well I don't know about
Georgia people moved there but you know
Kemp defeated Abrams handily DeSantis
gets this double-digit win and everyone
says things like he's a good leader he
had good messaging he cleaned up the
voting of the voting laws and and rules
all true but also consider all the
political refugees who went there and
wanted to vote for him they moved there
for him he attracted these people so
there's there's some good and there's
some bad and the bad is I was worried
about this that if people were going to
be fleeing yeah it would make red areas
redder and then you leave New York it
becomes Bluer in some respects though
that's how this whole thing was set up
to be right I mean the idea of
federalism that the states will be
extremely different experiments of
democracy and you will go somewhere that
is in line with your values that's
really how it was supposed to be you
know if New York
putting even New York aside because they
tried at least Cali just it's just never
coming back but if that's what they want
you know I still have some friends that
live there but it's like if that's what
you want I don't know what makes us
United anymore and unfortunately the
blue States will always encroach on the
red States Florida doesn't want anything
from a blue state right the blue States
will want the tax money and all the
resources of the functional red States
that's what that's what I think the next
Frontier but on the other hand we have
to understand Florida was a was a purple
is what I think was a purpose
barely won his first time around 30 000
votes so it was it was extremely close
and now this larger transition from New
Yorkers to Florida I think has
solidified Florida as a red State I
think there's like a but it's not what
they want sorry you said you said if
that's what they want in California but
it's not what's happening is
with with the the way their election
system works the more they weaken it now
they want to allow non-citizens to vote
yeah
a weekend election system means that for
all of The Selfish disinterested uh
voters they negate the Patriotic
hard-working American vote so for every
one of you out there who knows what's
going on wants energy policy fixed wants
Economic Policy fixed doesn't want our
borders open your vote is negated by
some guy who's playing Grand Theft
Auto's house when he has a knock on the
door and someone walks up and says
couldn't help but notice that you got
your mail today see that that's a ballot
did you fill it out and the guy says I
don't know man I don't care look just
fill it out it'll take 10 seconds and
then I'll leave and the guy goes okay
sure what am I doing Democrat okay here
you go man that one person who didn't
care canceled your vote even kind of but
what's happening is they're voting for
people to go do what you think they're
going to do and then they end up not
doing it because they get bribed like
this idea that we're in the best system
and this is the way it's supposed to be
I think is really messing with people
people think that they're in the this is
it we got there I don't think we need
like we only Built a republican like
representative house because we needed
to because as people couldn't represent
themselves they didn't have telephones
now we could 700 000 people could vote
yay or nay on a vote but we've talked
about it that's direct democracy that
doesn't work direct republicanism we
need a republic that's direct to the
people so that we don't have these
middle men that are getting bought out
by corporations
you want localism and you want
federalism so I I agree with you
actually that it's not that look first
off California has this basically the
most Republicans in the entire country
just because of the size of the state so
it's not that all of these people want
what they're getting there I would I'll
word it a little bit differently I would
say at some point you've got to just see
what day it is what time it is and you
got to get going and to me if you are a
freedom loving person who wants to own a
business and feel safe and not have
genderqueer Jam down your kid's throat
and everything else get the hell out of
Cali it's as simple as that it really is
to address what Ian was saying I think
you make an interesting point though so
let's look at this map right here of New
York right these counties they all
shifted towards the Republican Party
if you didn't need to send your votes
from say Utica
to the the Secretary of State or
whatever determine which individual
would run the state but instead you in
Utica voted for what you wanted then uh
I guess the idea you're saying is that
you're you're more likely to have your
voice heard as an individual every time
it would be heard but it's not it's not
direct democracy it's the district gets
a vote basic basically so if there's a
member of Congress representing a
district instead the district doesn't a
vote per issue or something like that
yeah so everyone in the district will
vote Yes or No and then the district
would be decided by that vote that would
go into the Senate so Congress would be
passing a bill and then the vote would
go out to uh everyone to see online and
then you'd vote in your district and
your District would get a vote based on
region but here's here's the point yeah
there's another there's some pros and
there's cons in this concept I mean for
one it still ultimately comes down to
ignorant people who don't care we'll end
up voting okay but Counterpoint it would
require the ballot Harvesters to go out
seven times a week to try and win these
votes and they wouldn't be able to do
that well that's one of the reasons that
the ballot harvesting works because
they're going to Blue cities blue cities
these are Democrats who want more
control they want more government in
their lives it's a lot harder to do it
you're going to go out to Utica and
you're going to go to Cornell and wander
around in the freezing cold and try to
get all these people people just aren't
going to do it that's that's the
Republican disadvantage but really think
about that we're staring at a freaking
completely red map with one one little
tiny dot of blue that people probably
can't even see if they're on their phone
and that is now governed by a Democrat
does that really make sense yeah
a Democrat who was one of the where I
would say the worst three heard Newsome
and and Whitmer one of the worst three
when it came to lockdowns and everything
else and the week before in the debate
she freaking said she would do it all
again and these people voted for her so
at some point if you're a sane person
there you gotta go all right maybe we
got a wrap up shop so here's the
challenge you leave New York and I've
said get out of the Cities go to the
middle of nowhere get some chickens
right you leave New York which makes it
you're basically clearing all obstacles
for for for these people to solidify
these rules and make them crazier and
worse you leave they will never lose
again you go to Florida you protect
Florida Florida and Texas seem to be
doing okay but all the other states are
now suffering and moving further and
further towards no you might have to
seed some ground I think we might be at
that place that all right here's what we
do
everyone in Florida have a bunch of kids
just start cranking them out 10 babies
per family then 18 years we send those
kids out all across the country start
colonizing blue cities listen I just had
two kids uh they're never they're never
leaving Florida these kids are gonna and
I'm being buried in Florida oh they're
going to be homeschooled or we'll figure
out some pod thing although that being
said Florida actually has pretty damn
good schools because of Mr DeSantis and
his don't say gay and they booted all
that stuff out of the schools so there
actually are pretty good public schools
in in Florida I don't know what we'll do
exactly but I would be less concerned
about that in Florida which was the joke
because Florida has no no
there's no they'll do that too and the
Santa DeSantis also got involved in
Local School Board elections yeah and
actually gave out recommendations for
candidates that he wanted to win which
made a big impact which is affecting the
schools down there and nobody's gonna
leave Hannah Navarro from The View she's
still she lives in Miami she complains
every day and she's not gonna get out oh
you heard what she said about yeah about
DeSantis right that he gained the system
game the system by arresting people
committing fraud yeah
she seems to think that black people
can't get IDs yeah I know a lot of black
people every single one of them but when
she was like he came to the system he
arrested people who committed fraud and
then credit police it's like what do you
think you're saying to people right now
yeah I really want to bump into her at a
restaurant one day she's on my short
list of people that I would say
something really you might in Florida
although all the politicians this in
Florida go to Florida AOC loves Florida
she vacations down in Miami all the time
she had she had her own people masked up
in New York and she went to that
freaking drag bar in Miami Beach and
then they paraded her around like she
was a queen like how vile oh man another
example of I want to get rid of the
House of Representatives I can't stand
these these faux celebrities getting
popularity contested into a bribery
state so annoying you know I don't I
don't I don't understand I don't know if
I agree with the get rid of the House of
reps but I do agree that um just because
we created this system which has been
one of the best so far or if not the
best
it doesn't mean we stop here you know
what I mean like there's there's always
got to be a way to do things better to
improve things you're right and I
shouldn't say get rid of the house I
don't that's not my intention is to
transition to a better form of
representation personal representation
well what if you just completely
handicap the federal government would
that basically do it for you short of
California right like that's what we
should all be going for that way as you
said you moved to Florida you moved down
here I moved to Florida we're all making
our choices and then the only issue then
if the federal government is not that
powerful is that the blue states don't
somehow encroach on the red States
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time